with dignity and respect
committed to free speech and common
sense and entertaining straight talking
and direct we may act eight each other
and you thought provoking provocative
and controversial hello and welcome to
the pledge now an intriguing photo
emerged this week that raised many
questions when was it taken by whom why
does someone in it appear to have an
entirely different haircut to their
current one and why for people who had
supposedly been arguing only days before
did they appear so affectionate but
while the world's media would focused on
that snap of boris and girlfriend Carrie
here at the pledge our very own Greg and
Carol were caught red-handed in this
compromising position whoever knew we
thought you hated each other
now Greg when was the picture taken what
I think that pictures about what false
is the one with Bob why do you look like
angular Merkel did you authorize its
release coming up I'm saying it's not
racist to charge health tourists for
using the NHS Greg once tougher
regulations to stop kids gambling June
believes men like MP mark field are
desperate to shut down powerful women
and Afra argues MPs shouldn't be forced
to choose between being a parent and
doing their job
but first it's Carol so Boris Johnson
has a shouting row with his girlfriend
having spilled red wine on her sofa and
suddenly he's not fit to be PM
apparently in Lala romaine Earl and
having shouty rouse in the privacy of
your own home it's proof positive you're
a violent despicable character not fit
to hold high office and the evidence for
this comes courtesy of to remainer
sneaks who taped the row between Boris
and girlfriend Kerry Simmons rang the
police and then passed the recording to
remain a newspaper which published parts
of the hacked conversation this is just
the latest in a long line of vicious
attempts of obsessive remainders who
having spent three
trying to trash the biggest people's
vote in Britain's history are now trying
to trash the People's Choice for PM
sorry
the purses arguments with his girlfriend
have absolutely nothing to do with his
ability to be PM he doesn't owe the
nation an account of what that rau was
about or the state of his relationship
because country to what's being claimed
it isn't in the national interest what
is or his policies his beliefs and his
promise to deliver breaks it again good
so a domestic altercation in the
neighbor's house would you stop to work
out whether there breaks the tea or
remainer before you decide whether you
should intervene what out what I
wouldn't do is tape the route first if I
believe someone's in danger and then
called the police which is what this
couple did I mean you clearly have a
very cynical view of the couple who
probably by the way other neighbors also
said that they'd been alarmed and they
were hearing this now from within their
own home so the idea that this is
somehow going out of your way to
eavesdrop on a private domestic
situation for me doesn't ring true they
heard it they taped it from within their
home an intrusive enough for them to
hear it in their own part let me ask you
a question I completely get the fact
that if you hear someone shouting and
screaming and you rightly would for the
safety you would ring the police I
completely get that I don't get why then
you would ring a national newspaper and
give a full transcript of that argument
to a national news every day with I let
me just say without the knowledge or
consent of the person you believed to be
the victim maybe they like I think that
that is relevant to the character of the
person who is putting himself forward
for a position of moral integrity
running the country my views on it some
more nuanced and I think you would
expect I actually would like us to get
away from the idea that and we've had
this debate if you're if you were
putting yourself forward for political
office you have to pretend to have a
perfect family life I think that's very
regressive I think it's fine for
politicians have complicated family lies
we all have complicated personal lives I
think
some of us can speak to that it is
particularly issue for me with this just
putting any allegation of domestic
violence or favors on the safety to the
side for a moment the issue for me is
honesty it's about honesty it's about
doing one thing or holding yourself out
to be one thing and being another when
it comes to Boris there are very valid
reasons to be skeptical about his
honesty and integrity as a person and
know it's not just me saying that and
you know I'mI'm a nolle I'm nada Tory
let me my taser happy Arbutus other no
right wing commentators who have
followed his career for decades and say
he's consistently a person who is not
honest I think that is relevant to the
debate and III don't know walking with
that
can I bring in what the neighbor
actually happen yesterday he said the
shouting was coming from a neighbor's
flat it was loud enough and angry enough
that I felt frightened and concerned for
the welfare of those involved so I went
inside my own home close the door and
press record on the voice memos app on
my phone my sole concern up until this
point was for the welfare and safety of
our neighbors once clear that no one was
harmed I contacted the Guardian as I
felt it was an important public interest
I believe it is reasonable for someone
who is likely to become our next prime
minister to be held accountable for all
of their words actions and behaviors you
cannot leave that room what yes you
leave it because at the end of the day
it's back to what F was said this is
about the person's temperament and it's
about their moral judgement it's
questionable re moral judgment but we
won't go there with Bobby you have shown
I think have you all had the way my
neighbors are pulling the police and
your point about why they pressed record
I would want okay you've been a pop
journalist oh yeah I'm not a pop Joe
just have a tabloid journalist Greg
there's the difference okay okay
populist resist all your life this was a
great popular story and and it was you
would have written it you and if it have
been about Corbin you be sitting here
let me take you in on that that point
this is the Guardian that led the moral
crusade against tabloid papers for
hacking in to the messages the phone let
me finish this this is hacking let
tapped into the messages let me just
finish the point tapped into the
messages not to the conversation this I
think is much much worse because what
they did was they taped they handed
verbatim a conversation from a public
figure held in the privacy of his own
room this is more than Phonak your
shouting loudly you I do just want to
because we're talking about the Guardian
and making allegations about whether it
was right for them to run the story so I
just want to let you know what they said
about it and this is from the Guardian
when a woman screamed at her partner to
get off me and get out of my flat
calling the police is a responsible
thing to do when police say no offenses
or concerns are apparent and no further
action is needed as on this occasion the
matter would in normal circumstances end
there but running for prime minister is
not by definition a normal circumstance
the public denied the right to choose
their leader have at least a right to
know who is being imposed upon us
scrutiny is not only appropriate it is
necessary I was right girlfriend this is
a story uniquely from which no one
emerges with any credit
I would suggest unfortunately all have
domestic rao's I do question the fact
that the neighbors having called the
police then decided to send it to a
newspaper that being said we're running
a newspaper of course I would have
attacked that story and I put it to your
card if I heard you correctly you said
that it isn't in the national interest
as to it I would suggest that this is a
man who is run and and I do draw the
line and I hear that we can get to
deeper this is a man who's effectively
his campaign is about character he is
the character who can deliver brexit he
is the character who can stare down
whoever he stares down in Brussels so if
we have a character who and I say again
my god we've all had domestic I could
probably beat you of many many times
over but all for put together but if I'm
seeking to be Prime Minister I at least
have to answer do I expect every last
bit and cough of course not it's none of
my business
we need a one paragraph statement
emotions were raised we're getting on
just fine and then
on we go to is in the it is in the now
when he does that okay so when he gives
that one your paragraph statement that
opens Pandora's but nobody does all the
other things that he's done in the past
the two wives the illegitimate child
why should he talk about but the point
is Vishnu who talked about the neighbors
of there were lots of other you know and
the get off quote specifically look at
in a slightly different way just look at
this in a different way when I have it
around with my husband would you know he
had he had fallen a month beause I mean
I have for a week but when I have around
with my husband he's trying to calm me
down he comes and tries to hold me and I
get off get off me get a look you say it
that's what I say because I'm not ready
I'm not ready to be comforted but when
the police say there was no crime
committed no offense committed no
domestic abuse we have to we had look
said that and remember the day they had
the day both of the matter yes it does
know the stresses of people then say
this you're making fun you would have it
he's a violent man that is the thing I
do the quick poll of my I don't know
that many toys but I did a quick poll of
half a dozen said I knew none of them
were gonna vote for bothers I get that
none of them were gonna vote for Bush
now he's gonna win nothing but I think
you shouldn't think it's as easy and
that's why he's people
that's why is people as scary scared
they're keeping him quite they know if
you let him out he could do disastrous
things and this is one he's like